[Music]
welcome
to the hall of heroes on august 22nd
comes an unprecedented global fan event
hello everybody it's all dc all the time
dc fandom is unlike anything you've ever
seen before
i'm actually standing inside a stage
that
jim lee himself drew how incredibly cool
is that it's crazy right
this worldwide mega event is for dc fans
across the globe
manafort we've got exclusive footage
insider info the latest dc news and huge
announcements
you know what i'm talking about there
was no way that i could come here and
not bring a look at the movie
there's so much cool content to look at
that was a really special episode
designed just for you the absolute dc
fan it's amazing
there's something that i can show you
exclusive content stuff that seems
impossible ends up becoming
possible i am beyond excited to be
sharing this moment with you guys
awesome hang on tight cause we are about
to whisk you around the dc fandom
are you guys ready let's get this thing
started
[Music]
dc fandom hall of heroes all fans
welcome
24 hours only august 22nd and there's
only one place you can experience
it at dc fandom.com
welcome back everyone it's charlie so
they dropped a big dc fandom trailer
with previews of all the trailers and
all the footage they're going to be
showing off in the panel so we'll break
it all down
and i'll explain what they've changed
about the event because they've kind of
broken it into two halves now
i'll be doing videos for all those big
trailers so be sure to subscribe to get
everything i'll be doing a special
giveaway during that too
i'll number these as we go along just to
say organized but just starting with the
big stuff first
matt reeves teasing new footage of the
batman movie of course
in the new muscle car version of the
batmobile like you look inside this
digital space this is all green screen
that they're standing on they just
create this digital environment
around them but as he says i couldn't
show up and not bring a new look at the
movie and then it zooms out and you see
the silhouette of the new batmobile
so obviously that's part of the new
footage that they're going to be showing
off
that's kind of the thing they do when
new batman movies and new versions of
batman come out christopher nolan did a
version of that same thing with
christian bale's batman before batman
begins came out
they showed off what christian bale's
batman was going to look like and then
they showed off the brand new version of
the batmobile the tumblr
and if you're old enough you might
remember them doing the exact same thing
way back in the 80s when they were
introducing michael keaton's batman for
the first time
way before they ever dropped the first
trailer for that batman movie
that was actually before studios dropped
trailers online so the only way to see
keaton in the batman costume or the
batmobile before that movie trailer
screened in a theater or on tv
was in print you literally had to buy a
magazine or a newspaper
we even just got the official first look
at the new batman
symbol so even though you've seen it on
the chest of robert pattinson's new
batman costume a lot of theories about
the easter eggs in this
and how he makes this batman symbol this
is what the symbol itself will look like
matt reeves new batmobile is a
combination of a couple different
modified muscle cars it's meant to be a
very batman year one year two early
prototype for what would later become
the more powerful
armored batmobiles he create later in
his career remember robert pattinson's
batman isn't supposed to be batman year
one but it's still
relatively early in his career like
batman year two or batman year three
like this is supposed to look like a car
that he could have bought off the street
from someone somewhere and they just
modified with a giant engine
more armor plating and weaponry to turn
it into like the derby car from hell and
just punish it up and down
gotham while he's chasing down villains
all over the streets
the footage that they showed off earlier
this year kind of gives you a look
inside the car
too very bare bones very rally car
looking but it does have electronics in
it it's just not
quite as advanced as the later
batmobiles from say like christian
bale's batman and the tumbler which was
a giant tank
or even keaton's batmobile which was
supposed to be a much more advanced
version of the car later in his career
i've already done a much more in-depth
video on the new batmobile design and
all the easter eggs that they showed off
so i'll add a link for that in the
description
and i'll put all the links for the
trailers that they release in the
descriptions of the videos this weekend
too
but it's also possible matt reeves shows
off a first look at catwoman
gordon and some of the other villains we
know what most of them look like or at
least have a pretty good idea the only
big change that i'm expecting from say
like previous batman like christian
bale's batman in this movie is that
robert pattinson isn't going to be
driving this car
on any rooftops or anything like that
remember the tumbler was literally a
giant modified military tank and this is
meant to be more of a traditional muscle
car that's just been armored up big time
he's also got a modified version of the
bat pod the batman motorcycle that he's
driving around and all the footage that
we saw earlier this year too
then there's james gunn and the whole
main cast of the suicide squad teasing
some footage and reveals of which
characters all of them are playing
i've done a couple videos about this
already because we do know who some of
them are playing but not all the
characters
that's why they have this giant zoom
call situation going on with all the
actors on screen at once that's why
there's so many of them
just to introduce who the big characters
are and who they're all playing i don't
know how much
literal footage they're gonna show off
from the actual movie or if it'll just
be them revealing the characters
most of the actual panels with the
directors talking about the movie the
themes the story the characters are only
going to be about a half an hour long
the teaser that james gunn dropped for
the suicide squad movie a couple of days
ago
just shows them doing a bunch of other
stuff too during that panel just having
fun
so it sounds like it'll be half them
talking about the movie the characters
the story and then the other half of
them just having fun
here it is everything it feels like high
school going to have
some uh competition jeopardy rules guys
pronounce it right
you can't just give away the point he's
not on our team
i thought you were on my team too
are you excited to be a part of dz
fandom it's gonna be quick i have a
little something special
in store for you i know a lot of you are
really excited about the games that
they're showing off there is some
injustice footage playing on the panels
here during the trailer and yes there
are rumors about injustice 3
actually happening but the big two games
that they're showing off
are the new suicide squad kills the
justice league game in the supposed new
batman arkham game
they've been dropping a bunch of weird
teasers for that supposed arkham game
the past couple of days
the funny thing about that too is they
keep saying watch this space
decode this teaser we have a big
announcement tomorrow and then tomorrow
comes and they drop another cryptic
teaser saying
decode this wait another day for more
info in the cycle of torture
repeats i don't know quite as much about
what's going on with the video games as
i do about the movies but the rumor
right now is that that new batman arkham
game is going to be a soft
reboot of the franchise there's a bunch
of aquaman footage playing during this
and yes there will be an aquaman 2 panel
with james wan maybe even jason momoa
zooming in
the wonder woman 1984 trailer that
they're going to be dropping
early in the morning will finally show
off more cheetah in full comic book
cheetah form i know everybody's just
been waiting to see it just hoping that
it doesn't look like the cats movie
no joke i think that they actually
freaked out when the cats movie came
out and they just tuned some of the
special effects for cheetah because that
happened a while ago they had plenty of
time to fix things if they wanted to fix
them before the movie came out
there's footage during this trailer of
the flash movie director
claiming he's got something from the
movie to show off i'm assuming it's
either
concept art of the brand new flash suit
or michael keaton's batman because right
now that's where most of the attention
is
and later in this trailer there's also
some footage from keaton's first batman
1989 movie
then there's a bunch of footage of zack
snyder in the justice league snyder cut
trailer he's been posting teasers every
day way more than the other directors so
he'll continue to do that up until his
actual panel
he'll continue to tweet out teasers like
this for the next couple of days
so it'll just be fun to see what it is
that he releases the trailer that he's
going to be showing off on saturday will
just be a much more complete much
longer version of an actual trailer most
of the footage he's shown off so far
are really just small clips from the
movie that they've strung together like
superman in the black suit i've already
done a couple videos about that
there's the wonder woman dark side scene
i've talked about that they also weirdly
have footage of the joker movie with
joaquin phoenix in this trailer too but
i don't think they have any big
announcements about a joker sequel or
anything like that
on the tv show side things they're
showing off the flash season 7
trailer i'm assuming it's mostly reverse
flash
red death setup stuff because originally
that was going to be their season 6
finale but then they had to cancel
those episodes because of the virus
during the trailer they say that this is
going to be available worldwide but if
you find that it's not available in your
country for some reason
just use a vpn oftentimes that's the
solution to so many
problems but you also probably heard
that they broke dc fandom into two
different days
what they did is is they're going to do
most of the movie stuff
this saturday all the big movie trailers
and everything then a couple weeks later
on september 12th they're gonna do the
other half of the panels for most of the
other tv shows in the lesser stuff
so all the big stuff is happening this
weekend as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
all those videos when i post them
while you wait for everything click here
for the boys season 3 teaser of jensen
ackles in the character that he's gonna
be playing during season three it's
hilarious
and click here for the batman teaser
trailer video thank you so much for
watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys
[Music]
tonight
you